[Musique]
la grande difficulté que nous avons surmontée, c'est que
parfois nous recevons un patient qui
arrive trop tard et puis il est trop tard
pour sauver des vies et même si nous
pouvons perdre la vie d'un patient, c'est
vraiment quelque chose  cela restera dans ton
cœur et est vraiment
[Musique]
touchant
[Musique] [Musique]
devant [
Musique]
moi, nous recevons uniquement des grossesses à haut risque
ou des grossesses compliquées par exemple
les femmes multigravides cela signifie qu'elles
ont déjà eu beaucoup d'enfants donc
elles  sommes plus à risque d'hémorragie post-partum
et de beaucoup de pertes de sang
journaliste nous comprenons le
problème mais euh vous savez